-Making her TV debut,
performing "Salad"
from her self-titled
debut album,
give it up for Blondshell.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Keep an eye out
for his pickup ♪
♪ I know all about it ♪
♪ I would take 'em all out with
some poison in his salad ♪
♪ And it wouldn't be so bad ♪
♪ It wouldn't hurt the world ♪
♪ Look what you did ♪
♪ You'll make a killer of
a Jewish girl ♪
♪♪
♪ And you did it to a lady ♪
♪ Oh, you have a family ♪
♪ How does someone end up with
a stone in a chest cavity? ♪
♪ It wouldn't be so bad ♪
♪ It wouldn't hurt the world ♪
♪ Look what you did ♪
♪ Now in my sleep,
I am a murderer ♪
♪ It doesn't happen to him,
and I know ♪
♪ I put it in a box,
in a TV show ♪
♪ It doesn't happen to him,
and I know ♪
♪ God, tell me,
why did he hurt my girl? ♪
♪♪
♪ And she took him
to the courthouse ♪
♪ And somehow, he got off ♪
♪ And I saw him laughing with
his lawyer in the parking lot ♪
♪ It wouldn't be so bad ♪
♪ It wouldn't hurt like this ♪
♪ Look what you did ♪
♪ You'll make a killer of
a pacifist ♪
♪ It doesn't happen to him,
and I know ♪
♪ I put it in a box,
in a TV show ♪
♪ It doesn't happen to him,
and I know ♪
♪ God, tell me,
why did he hurt my girl? ♪
♪♪
♪ Gonna get big ♪
♪ I'm so scary ♪
♪ I can't stop having
visions of following him ♪
♪ Gonna make it hurt ♪
♪ But I don't know how to
do that within the framework ♪
♪ 'Cause we were never violent ♪
♪ Oh, oh, yeah ♪
♪ Gonna get big ♪
♪ I'm so scary ♪
♪ I can't stop having
visions of following him ♪
♪ Gonna make it hurt ♪
♪ But I don't know how to
do that within the framework ♪
♪ 'Cause we were never violent ♪
♪♪
♪ Gonna get big ♪
♪ I'm so scary ♪
♪ I can't stop having
visions of following him ♪
♪ Gonna make it hurt ♪
♪ But I don't know how to
do that within the framework ♪
♪ 'Cause we were never violent ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]